personally I I would say and this didn't
exist when I was younger it's not
necessarily a year out but spend some
time doing a lot of different jobs
because doing a lot of different jobs
you do find out what you don't like so
we mentioned McDonald's there so you
could flip burgers for two weeks if you
wanted to learn the ropes of the
McDonald's trade then quit then go on to
your next job learn that job see what
you didn't like from it take the things
you did and then put them together in
the third job you go to so I think
taking a year away to find out what you
don't like is a great way to do things
and then if the choice is to go to
university because you want to be XYZ
that needs that then of course you go
but the problem with going when you
don't know what you want to do is that's
a lot of debt that's a hell of a lot of
debt and that debt at some Point's got
to be paid off and you may never go into
that job or use that degree ever again
in your life so is a bit of a waste I
think for a lot of people yeah
even in the UK where you know some
people would say it's not really debt
it's more like a graduate tax so it's
only nine percent and you only have to
pay off once you're earning more than
25k or whatever the number is do you
think the debt thing is still a factor
that people should seriously consider
um I think so because I think it also
limits their job options as well because
most people that come out of University
feel there of a certain level that you
don't want to earn below a certain level
and you are going to be paying it back
nine times out of ten
um but you also job trap yourself to a
certain degree as well well most people
that I know that have been to University
that haven't got jobs are like well you
know I can't find a job for my
qualifications and you think well that's
because you've studied something you
didn't want to study in the first place
and there wasn't any job opportunities
for that and whoever promised you that
University course was going to give you
a good living at the end of it
essentially lie to you because it's not
there but it is a business University
isn't it at the end of the day there's a
lot of people making a lot of money
pushing a lot of people through whether
it's through the University whether it's
through the accommodation or whether
it's through student units or whatever
it is there's a lot of money being out
so I can understand why people push
youngsters that way because in a way is
an easy option isn't it if you don't
know what to do you've got three
straight four years of wow I'm going to
University I'm working hard everyone
thinks I am but then the reality will
hit after that so again not against
University before anyone feels that way
but I think a lot that go probably
shouldn't yeah I think I'm I would I
would broadly agree with that I think
yeah in in some schools in some in some
backgrounds it's just you know in my
school like 100 of people went to
University and it would it was like
really weird if you didn't and the same
at my son's school as well I mean my son
every single person in his school
leaving in his year went to University
he deliberately did not go to the open
days of the University because he knew
he didn't want to go and if he went to
the open days then they would probably
coerce him into wanting to go you know
like you can join this team you can be
on that team you can do this the
nightlife's great and he felt that it
would hold him back and I think that's
the bravest decision he's ever made
because if everyone around you is going
you say no I'm not you're actually the
strong one in that situation and he's
now built obviously a business with my
what he built a business before we
worked together but now we work together
on YouTube and everything else that we
do and on the podcast strike it big and
it's it's a fantastic relationship
because of that hey friends thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day bye